-Welcome back. Welcome back.
-God, I might as well move in.
-I love having you here.
I know.
How is your daughter?
How is she doing?
-She's pretty great.
Marlowe. She's 10.
-She's 10?
-It happens like that.
-Really does.
-It really does.
But she's amazing.
-We spoiled her
last time she was here.
-Yeah.
-She came with you.
But we had puppies on the show.
-Oh, my God.
-And she was like...
And she was like, "What?"
And we put her
and she just stayed in her room
with, like, 15 puppies.
She's like, "This is
the best show ever."
-I tell her I'm going to work,
like, every time she comes,
she's like, looking at me --
"This is not work."
-Yeah, this is play.
-Surrounded by puppies.
-Yeah, we're playing
with puppies.
-"You can't fool me."
-Are you still doing the thing
where you play an album
a week for her?
-So, we did that
for a long time,
and now there is no way on Earth
that I could make her
sit through an album a week.
It's actually -- She's got
great music taste,
and I would like to think
that I had a hand in that
through the early...
-She's taking over now.
-She's taken over,
and it's a role reverse.
She actually educates me.
-She tells you about her...
-About current popular music,
because I'm stuck in the --
I don't know.
-Yeah.
-Another century.
-Yeah, but, so who has she
turned you on to?
-It was a lot of Taylor Swift.
A lot of...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, who we love.
-Yes!
-Yes, we love her.
Olivia Rodrigo.
-Yes.
-You know,
and sort of quite emo...
emo...pop?
-Yeah.
Have you taken her to a concert?
-Can you tell
I've got a 10-year-old?
I'm like, "Emo," you know.
-Yeah.
-There's all these things.
I mean, I'm not --
I'm not cool anymore.
"Sus."
-Don't be sus.
-You guys are being sus,
a little bit, yeah.
-What's sus? Oh, no. "Shipping."
Have you heard shipping?
-No.
-She's like, "So, he was
totally shipping her,"
which means...
crushing on, I think?
-Oh.
-I'm like, "Shipping, you say?"
What is "ship"?
-"Shipping, you say?"
-Is this nautical?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, like,
just not cool anymore, no.
-No, you're totally cool.
What are you talking about?
-I think so.
But she does not.
-Really?
-No.
-But have you been --
have you been to a concert?
-So, I took her to Taylor Swift.
That was her first concert.
She was about 5.
-Oh, my God.
-Or 6. Yeah.
-Amazing.
And I took her and her cousins
and her best friend,
and I was definitely the oldest
and most enthusiastic member
of that audience.
And we know Taylor,
very fortunately,
so we got to go backstage
afterwards, which was a dream.
But she was like,
"I saw you singing
every single word of my song."
Like, I was like...
-And she was a little worried?
-She was just like,
she's like,
"You are a big fan."
I was like, "Yep, yep."
-Wow, so you were right
up close and like...?
-Yeah, I was just like, "Yeah!"
-Yeah.
-No, I went -- I, like...
-♪ Shake it off ♪
Yeah. Just yelling at her.
-Yeah.
-I don't know what to do
at concerts at all.
-If you're with your kids,
you cannot dance.
You cannot look happy.
-No.
-You cannot sing every word.
-What was your first concert?
Do you remember?
-My first concert
was Oasis in 1996.
-What?!
[ Audience cheers ]
-It was.
I took my best friend
and we went to Earl's Court,
and it was like,
it's an iconic gig that we like,
snuck out and went to.
I was 14 or something.
-Oh, my God.
-But I was, I was convinced
that they looked at me,
that Liam Gallagher
looked at me in the eye.
-Yeah.
-I was like, I know he saw me.
I was so in love with him.
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah.
"We're going to get married."
This is so cool.
I can't believe.
-It was on.
It was on from then.
Actually, my mother then met
Noel Gallagher
in Harrods or something.
Like, he was shopping
and she went up and she went,
"My daughter is going
to marry Liam."
He's like,
"I don't think so, actually."
"I don't think she is."
And now he's one
of my best mates,
which I will tell everybody.
And I did drop that name
and I will continue to do so.
-Noel Gallagher
-So now I'm Team Noel.
-I love...
Yeah, I love Noel Gallagher.
-Yeah, he's the best.
-I love both of them. Yeah.
-And his band's amazing.
The new stuff is so fantastic.
Yeah.
-Yeah, they're...
That's a great
first concert to go to.
-Yeah.
-My first was Weird Al Yankovic.
-Oh, my God.
That is so on-brand.
-It's perfect, right?
-I've never loved you more.
-It's kind of perfect.
-Of all the things
you could have said,
that's like, it's perfect.
-It was perfect.
It was my favorite. Yeah.
-The rest is history.
Here you are.
-And Oasis is perfect
for you, too.
This kind of fits.
-Yeah.
-I know you're not a stranger
to performing onstage.
You were in "Cabaret," singing.
-Yes.
-And you --
I don't know if we've told
the story on the show.
It makes me laugh.
It's sad, but it's funny.
-It's sad.
I was doing "Cabaret,"
and the big number
in "Cabaret" is,
funnily enough,
a song called "Cabaret."
And the way
that we staged it
was like one spotlight
in the eyes.
So it's like you're blind.
It goes to a blackout
and you're blind.
The only way to get offstage
is to stand there
with your arms out
and be led off
because the back wall moves in
for the next scene.
However, one night,
the man did not show up,
and I heard the wall move
and I was like,
I can't be stumbling around
in the platform.
It's going to ruin the show.
So I ran in the direction
of offstage.
I slammed...
Alan Cumming was the emcee.
He heard like a...
[ Claps ]
That doesn't...
Well, like...
It was a skull on...
Thank you.
Yeah, a skull on metal,
and I felt, like, warm blood
and I was just like, "I've just
got to finish the show."
Climbed up the stairs.
I'm standing in this balcony,
blood dripping down.
Eight stitches, got a nice scar.
And then the next day,
they were like --
there was a matinee,
and they were like,
"Are you sure
you want to do the show?"
And I was like...
I had the biggest black eye.
I was like, "Just put on
more lashes!"
And Sally Bowles
has to, like, look at people
in the audience
and kind of flirt with them.
And the men were hor-- I mean,
it was honestly like
I literally had like half an eye
that was black and...
and like loads of...
It was just not okay.
-Oh, I think that's so funny.
Come on.
See, that's a trouper, though.
-War wounds.
-Yeah, that's a professional.
That's what we do.
-The show must go on.
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about this show.
"Extrapolations."
It's on Apple TV+.
Meryl Streep, by the way,
plays your mom.
I don't want to spoil anything.
But is that the reason,
one of the reasons you did it?
-I mean, I think
if I got -- I got an email
from Scott Z. Burns and it said,
"I would love you to do this."
We'd worked together
on "The Loudest Voice."
He'd directed
an episode of that.
So we were friends.
And then there was a P.S. --
"Meryl Streep is playing
your mother,"
at which point I was like,
"I don't need to read it.
I'm in."
You know, that's a bucket list,
isn't it, for any of us?
-Oh, my gosh.
-Like to even be
in the room.
-What was she like?
-Oh, she's awful.
[ Laughter ]
Really, no, she's the best.
I mean, she's the best.
She's like everything
that you would want and more.
-I know you're you,
but do you get nervous
when you're next
to Meryl Streep?
Do you go, like...
-Yes, let alone having
to look her in the eyes
and, like, act?
-Yeah.
-'Cause all you want to do
is watch what she's doing.
She's so brilliant, which is
news to everyone, I know.
She's a really great actor.
[ Laughter ]
-At the end of every episode,
there's a screen
where people can go on a website
and get more information
about climate crisis.
And that website is...
-Yes.
-So go there, check it out,
see what you can do
to help the climate.
The series finale
came out today.
I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Sienna Miller
in "Extrapolations."
Take a look.
-Dr. Shearer,
were you paid for your work
at Menagerie2100?
-Yes.
-Depressing work, I'm sure.
All that saying goodbye.
Yes?
That explains
why you receive
mood-stabilizing therapeutics
from Alpha.
Ms. Shearer relies on Alpha for
her retirement and her medicine.
What if her ongoing depression
has caused her to blame
the medicines
that Alpha provides her with?
-I know you want people
to think I'm crazy, Mr. Turner,
and maybe --
maybe I am.
Maybe that's what climate change
is doing to all of us.
Some of us are crazy
because we look at the world
and all we have lost,
and we still have hope.
-Come on, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're fantastic.
Who's better?
Sienna Miller!
Who's better than Sienna Miller?
"Extrapolations" is streaming
now on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody.